the Barbary Pirates were Raiders which
plagued the Mediterranean for three
centuries they attacked ship stole cargo
and sold the crews into bondage in spite
of the obvious cost to the European
Naval Powers none of them did much about
them and it wasn't until the early 19th
century that the Barbary Pirates were
dealt with with the United States which
was only about 30 years old at this
point leading the charge which raises
the question why why was the United
States first to deal with the Barbary
Pirates and not say France or Spain so
as of the late 18th century the Barbary
Pirates operated from these North
African States the most notorious being
Algiers over the previous centuries the
European Naval Powers had learned that
fighting the Pirates was a lot of effort
and so they came up with the genius
strategy pay them off this wasn't cheap
but it was cheaper than war and for
Nations like Britain the bribing of the
Pirates formed a Cornerstone of their
Naval strategy in the region Britain was
quick to pay the Pirates a much larger
sum of money which meant that the other
states had to pay more whilst places
like Spain and France could afford to
take the hit smaller States like general
or Sicily struggle old and thus they
would be forced to rely on British
shipping instead so when the United
States opted out of taxation without
representation in 1776 the protection
that Britain had paid for was no longer
valid for American shipping thus the
next 25 years saw numerous U.S vessels
attacked and the cost of paying off the
Pirates was extortionate for the new
nation and thus something needed to be
done and so it was time to send in the
Navy in 1801 along with the Swedish the
United States made war against the
Barbary States they weren't the first to
do so the Spanish had spent substantial
sums of money in the 1780s trying to
destroy them but to no avail the
American strategy was mostly blockades
and bombardments of ports which didn't
lead to much until the U.S opted to work
with the former deposed ruler of Tripoli
together they marched into tripolitania
and forced its current ruler to make
peace or face potential Civil War the
terms of this piece weren't exactly
great for the US which agreed to pay
Tripoli lots of cash in return for the
release of American prisoners and for
safe passage of American shipping this
safe passage didn't last too long and
when the War of 1812 kicked off the
British pushed the Barbary states to
step up attacks on American shipping
after the war was over the US government
opted to deal with the piracy issue for
good Having learned from the last war
the U.S sent even more ships with more
guns to get the message across they
hunted down the pirates from Algiers
before demanding that this rule to stop
any and all raiding of American shipping
or our cheers would be destroyed its
rulers agreed and the Americans returned
home these Barbary States still existed
of course but given that a smaller power
like the US has just defeated them this
led to the remaining Naval Powers
realizing that they too didn't have to
put up with it and given that they were
no longer fighting each other they
decided that the Barbary States had to
go the British were the first to strike
bombarding Algiers several times as
punishment for piracy however it wasn't
until the 1830s when France annexed
al-jeason took control of its Port the
Barbary raiding came to a complete halt
I hope you enjoyed this episode with a
special thanks to my patrons James
bizzinet Kelly moneymaker kosher wolf
katoitska Alex Schwinn Andy mcgehi Jerry
lambdin rod D Martin a firefly Marcus
arsner why in hockey Spencer Lightfoot
Marvin Castle Captain said okay Moon
Yoon Winston K would miss izzette boogly
Wiggly Maggie pascowski the macquapo
Gustav Swan calling Dr Howard Dr Fine Dr
Howard Coppertone shuenin spinning three
plates words about books podcast Jim
Stromberg words about books podcast and
Charles the first